1.3 billion years ago two orbiting
massive black holes circling each other
at 250 times a second collided in a
violent universe rippling explosion that
sent waves of energy throughout the
cosmos in its wake a new super massive
black hole formed over 60 times bigger
than our Sun fast forward to September
2015
gravitational waves from this ancient
cosmic event finally struck earth
luckily the gravitational waves weakened
over such a great distance but what if
we weren't so lucky if a couple of black
holes in our solar system collided could
we survive what would happen to earth if
we got hit by massive gravitational
waves what causes these waves and how
can we detect them this is what if and
here's what would happen if a
gravitational wave hit earth in 1916
Albert Einstein made waves himself with
his groundbreaking theory of general
relativity known famously by the formula
e equals MC squared or energy equals
mass times a speed of light squared he
proved energy and mass are
interchangeable and that space or
space-time curves in relation to the
energy and momentum of whatever matter
and radiation are present with great
foresight Einstein inferred the
collision of black holes or massive
stellar objects create distortions and
gravity which are pushed out in all
directions
thanks to incredible developments in
atomic measurement scientists in
Washington and Louisiana in the u.s. at
the laser interferometer
gravitational-wave Observatory or LIGO
for short were able to detect and
measure the first-ever gravitational
waves here on earth in 2015 this was a
historic moment in science as it was the
first definitive proof of Einstein's
theory of relativity using laser
interferometry observatories can detect
a change less than ten thousandth the
diameter of a proton that's 1 million
times smaller than the width of a human
hair
since then likeö has measured 50
detection of gravitational waves so what
exactly is causing these waves and could
they be catastrophic
there are many sources of gravitational
waves including the collision of black
holes the rotation of a symmetrical
neutron stars supernovae or even
remnants of gravitational radiation
caused by the Big Bang these waves
travel at the speed of gravity equal to
the speed of light and emanate outward
in all directions like a rock being
thrown in a pond
the ripples it creates dissipate over
great distances and become smaller and
smaller luckily in our pocket of the
universe we are over 400 million light
years away from any orbiting black holes
we're generally safe but if these black
holes happen to be in our solar system
the
patience are much more dire when
gravitational waves pass through a
planet one side is compressed as the
other expands kind of like squeezing a
stress ball I could use one of those
right now as a result time and space
itself are stretched causing a slight
wobble but if we were closer to this
violent event and the waves were much
bigger this impact could potentially
tear our planet apart triggering
powerful continents splitting
earthquakes volcanic eruptions and epic
storms earth wouldn't really be a
habitable place anymore except maybe for
extremel files like bacteria that thrive
in hydrothermal vents let's imagine our
son was a neutron star of an imperfect
non spherical shape sending
gravitational ripples outward as it
spins earth would likely look more like
IO
one of Jupiter's moons which is put
under great gravitational pressure by
Jupiter and as a result is one of the
most volcanically active moons in the
solar system our landscape would be
covered in lava and volcanic fallout
with an atmosphere made up of toxic
gases like hydrogen sulfide this would
cause massive global warming and intense
storms constant tsunamis tornadoes and
well you get the idea
climate chaos we can count our blessings
we are nowhere near any massive object
shooting out gravitational waves but
thankfully we can still measure them and
learn more about the complexities of our
universe even though we get hit by
gravitational waves they are generally
so small we can't even feel any impact
but on the flip side what would it be
like if we suddenly lost our gravity
well that sounds like a story for
another what if
[Music]
you
[Music]